many of the mariupl residents who have
not been able to safely evacuate lack
food water electricity and medical care
uncollected corpses lie on city streets
yesterday's strike on the mariupl
theatre which reportedly served as a
bomb shelter for displaced civilians
adds to the list of attacks against
civilian structures
while early reports indicate that the
worst may have been avoided ongoing
fighting is hampering the rescue work
and assessment of the situation
mr president the devastation and
suffering in mario paul and harkeef
raises grave fears about the fate of
millions of residents of kiev and other
cities facing intensifying attacks
international humanitarian law is
crystal clear
civilians are entitled to protection
against the dangers arriving from
military operations
direct attacks on civilians are
prohibited
yet
the magnitude of civilian casualties and
the destruction of civilian
infrastructure in ukraine cannot be
denied
this demands a thorough investigation
and accountability
mr president the priority for the un and
its partners is to reach the people
trapped by the ongoing shelling
including in eastern ukraine
to that end we continue to scale up our
operations on the ground as
circumstances permit
the needs of the population are growing
by the day
the u.n calls for safe passage for
civilians from and humanitarian supplies
into encircled areas
we are grateful to neighboring
governments for their generosity in
receiving refugees and enabling the
provision of assistance to ukraine
the un is requesting all donors to
fast-track funding against pledges made
for the ukraine flash appeal
the appeal which seeks 1.1 billion
dollars to help 12 million people in
need is 36 funded
mr president undp projects that 90 of
the ukrainian population could be facing
poverty and extreme economic
vulnerability should the war continue
setting the country and the region back
decades and leaving deep social and
economic scars
as the secretary general highlighted
dangerous ripple effects of the conflict
are already being felt across the globe
russia and ukraine represent more than
half of the world's
supply of sunflower oil and 30 percent
of the world's wheat
food fuel and fertilizer prices are
skyrocketing
supply chains are being disrupted
all of this is hitting the poorest the
hardest and potentially creating
instability around the globe
the secretary general announced on 14
march the establishment of a global
crisis response group on food energy and
finance to lead an effort with member
states to deal with the complex fallout
of the war
the deputy secretary general will lead
an interagency steering committee with
partners to oversee this effort
mr president the secretary general
welcomes all ongoing diplomatic contacts
he remains actively engaged with leaders
who are trying to bring about an end to
this war
there will be no winners to this
senseless conflict
the tremendous loss it is causing on the
other hand is heartbreakingly clear
and it is going to get much much worse
the longer the fighting continues
the secretary general urges intensified
and coordinated political efforts for an
immediate succession of hostilities
there must be a meaningful sustained
political process to enable a peaceful
settlement
the lives of millions of ukrainians and
the peace and security of the entire
region and possibly beyond depend on it
thank you mr president
i just got to say that
i thank mr carlo
mr president it has been
less than
three weeks since high commissioner
gandhi addressed this council within
this short time span the number of
refugees from ukraine in the neighboring
countries has risen exponentially from
the then
520 000
to over 3.1 million today in what has
become the fastest growing refugee
crisis in europe since world war ii
with close to 2 million refugees from
ukraine
poland has in a matter of a few weeks
become one of the largest refugee
hosting countries in the world
some
490 000 people have fled to romania
350 000 to moldova
280 000 to hungary and 228
000 to slovakia
hundreds of thousands have now reached
other european countries
a sizable number of people have also
moved to the russian federation and to a
smaller extent to belarus
we are humbled by the remarkable
resilience of the refugees many of whom
have left their home with next to
nothing
and by the extraordinary hospitality of
the host authorities and host
communities
this solidarity illustrates the very
foundation of the international refugee
protection architecture and the spirit
of the global compact on refugees
the acts of compassion humanity and
kindness
we now witness daily bring hope and
brighten and otherwise very grim reality
we strongly commend the governments of
for receiving
of receiving countries for keeping their
borders open
to all those fleeing ukraine including
third country nationals who must
continue to be received without any
discrimination
the robust response that these countries
have mounted from scratch in an
extremely short period of time is truly
impressive
we are heartened by the bilateral and
other support extended to the principal
refugee hosting countries and the
funding committed to us so far in
support of the 1.1 billion
u.s dollar flash appeal for the response
inside ukraine and for the
550.6 million us dollars towards the
unhcr led regional refugee response plan
both
launched on the 1st of march
the outpouring of support from the
private sector and individuals who have
jointly provided some two-thirds of the
funds raised for the response so far
must be loaded
all international support to the
response is coordinated under the
refugee coordination model led by unhcr
which has been established in poland
moldova hungary romania and slovakia as
well as in other countries in the region
the sum of collective expertise and
support will be critical to help the
refugee population and support host
countries with shelter emergency relief
items cash assistance as well as mental
health and psycho social psychosocial
support
indonesia has scaled up its response by
deploying over 200 experts and
established field presence in all
countries initial staff on the ground
and they take regular protection
monitoring at the main border crossing
points reception centers and other
locations where refugee transit or
gather
however
with the current pace of refugee
outflows the capacity of neighboring
countries are being tested and stretched
we can and must do more to support and
we must do it now
as the situation evolves unhcr in
coordination with the host government
and partners will assess the needs as
necessary and is currently adjusting the
regional refugee response lab
while some refugees transit through
countries neighboring ukraine many also
join families which have long settled in
these countries this is particularly the
case in poland
where with time passing and resources
diminishing the number of refugees
needing integration will rise
they and the state which host them will
need support to ensure their inclusion
in all sectors of public life health and
education access to labor and other
services
with eu host countries receiving support
from the rest of the union we are
particularly concerned about the
situation in moldova where over
350 000 people have arrived
this refugee crisis comes on top of
pre-existing challenges it is therefore
crucial that sufficient resources are
made available quickly to support the
government's response
as critical as it is funding is only one
of the many forms of support that are
urgently needed
we commend the recent launch of the eu
solidarity platform designed to ease the
pressure on the country's neighboring
ukraine through transfers of vulnerable
refugees to the other eu member states
we are grateful to those member states
that have already made concrete pledges
to transfer refugees from moldova and
encourage others to join this initiative
which constitutes a remarkable and
innovative example of responsibility
sharing in line with the key tenets of
the global compact on refugees
in addition the eu activated for the
first time in its history the temporary
protection directive which enables
refugees asylum seekers and stateless
persons
to arriving in ukraine
to quickly regularize their legal status
alleviating pressure on asylum systems
it shall also enable refugees to find
work access services and benefit from
social protection
such temporary protection has also been
announced by the governments of the
united states canada switzerland brazil
and others
mr president
i wish to further highlight that 90
percent of the refugees fleeing ukraine
are women and children indicating the
heightened risk of gender-based violence
and other forms of exploitation and
abuse including trafficking
as the secretary general said for
predators human traffickers
and human traffickers war is not a
tragedy it is an opportunity
we are deeply concerned about media
reports of incidents of gender-based
violence and trafficking and are
supporting the efforts of government in
scaling up prevention and risk
mitigation measures including through
the stay safe campaign aimed at
awareness raising and provision of
information to refugees
as part of unhcr's leading role in
coordinating the u.n refugee response we
have also deployed experts in psca
coordinators to support the government
response in several refugee hosting
countries
mr president since the early days of
this crisis unhcr committed to stay and
deliver in ukraine and this is what we
have done allow me to take this
opportunity to express our deepest
gratitude and admiration for our
colleagues who have remained in ukraine
but also to the whole humanitarian
community
we believe that at least 2 million
people have been forced to flee within
ukraine close to 13 million people have
been affected in the hardest hit area
and the hardest and hardest hit
by the war in ukraine
many people remain trapped in areas of
escalating conflict and with essential
services disrupted are unable to meet
even the most basic of their needs in
many locations such as mario paul
residents face a critical and
potentially fatal shortage of food water
and medicines
people living with disability or serious
medical condition
are particularly impacted unhcr is
closely tracking
negotiation for safe passage and is
preparing to send humanitarian supplies
as soon as conditions allow
to facilitate the provision of
life-saving assistance to the population
most in need in ukraine we have adjusted
our operational presence relocating
offices and warehouses to the western
and central parts of the country
together with partners we have been able
to deliver critical supplies for
displaced and conflict-affected
populations including core relief items
and shelter materials
we are working closely with local
authorities to establish and expand
reception capacity in main locations
where internally displaced people arrive
we coordinate the protection the
provision
of key protection services such as legal
aid social accompaniments psycho
psychosocial support child protection
and gender-based violence case
management
where conditions allow we distribute
multi-purpose cash to help people make
choices best suited to their needs
flexible forms of assistance are crucial
as our innovative approaches
despite all efforts we are unable to
respond to the sheer scale of the
rapidly growing
needs of the ukrainian people and
systematically deliver the much
the much needed life-saving assistance
we cannot overemphasize the urgent call
repeatedly made by the secretary general
usg dicarlo erc griflit civilians and
civilian infrastructure must be
protected
international humanitarian law must be
upheld and safe passage for civilians in
any direction they choose must be
enabled
safe humanitarian access to those in
need
and unhindered delivery of aid including
through a functioning humanitarian
notification system remains of paramount
importance mr president
in conclusion allow me to paraphrase
high commissioner gandhi who is today in
tajikistan after having left afghanistan
yesterday on numerous occasions he
stressed that as we respond to the
crisis in ukraine we cannot abandon or
forget other recent and protracted
humanitarian crisis in many regions of
africa
latin america asia and the middle east
thank you
allah
[Music]
mr president
excellencies
dear colleagues
good afternoon
and thank you for the opportunity to
address it today
the war in ukraine is having
a devastating consequence
for the health of ukraine's people
consequences
that will reverberate
for years
or decades to come
there is severe disruption to health
services
and access to basic commodities
as a result of widespread destruction of
infrastructure
including health
facilities who
has verified 463 attacks on health care
with 12 people killed
and 34 injured
including health workers
in any conflict
attacks on health care
are a violation of international
humanitarian law
they deprive people of urgently needed
care
and break already restrained
health systems
the disruption to services and supplies
in ukraine is posing an extreme risk to
people with cardiovascular
disease
cancer
diabetes hiv
and tb
which are among the leading cause of
mortality in ukraine
displacement
poor shelter
and overcrowded living conditions caused
by the conflict are likely to increase
the risk of diseases such as measles
pneumonia
and
polio services for mental health and
psychosocial support are urgently needed
to help people cope with the effects
of the war
there are
more than 35 000 mental health patients
in ukrainian psychiatric hospitals
and long-term care facilities
which are facing severe shortages of
medicines
food
heating blankets
and more
the war is also exacerbating the impact
of the coveted 19 pandemic in ukraine
with just one third of the adult
population fully vaccinated
this increases the risk of large numbers
of people developing
severe disease
critical shortages of oxygen will have
an impact on the ability to treat
patients with coffee 19 and many other
conditions
at least eight facilities
for producing and storing liquid oxygen
have now closed
and we're seeking ways of accessing
oxygen from neighboring countries
and ways to deliver it
safely to where it's needed
double h choice on the ground
working with the ministry of health and
partners to support health workers
and the health system to provide care to
meet immediate health needs
so far we have sent about 100 metric
tons of medical supplies including
oxygen insulin surgical supplies
anesthetics and blood transfusion kits
enough
for
thousand five hundred trauma patients
and forty four hundred fifty thousand
primary health care patients for one
month
other equipment including oxygen
generators
electrical generators
and defibrillate letters
have also been delivered and we're
preparing to send the further 108 metric
tons
we have now established supply lines
from our warehouse in live
to many cities of ukraine
but challenges with access
remain
we need unfettered access
we have critical supplies ready
for you and joined convoys to enter
difficult areas
but so far
we have not been successful
today for example the un convoy to sumi
that included a wg truck carrying
critical medical supplies was unable to
enter
loads ready for maripo
remain in staging areas and cannot
proceed
access to this
and other areas
is now critical
to support ukraine cell system
who is coordinating the deployment of 20
emergency medical teams
consisting of experts from many
countries
to deliver care across a range of
disciplines
in ukraine and neighboring countries
which have been
generous in welcoming refugees but are
struggling to meet their needs as my
colleagues earlier said
those needs are immense
and include continuity of care for basic
illnesses
as well as more complex issues like
cancer and renal dialysis
maternal and child health hiv and tb
sexual and reproductive health and
mental health
refugees and many of those who remain in
ukraine are already very vulnerable
especially
women
and girls
protecting them from abuse and
exploitation of all kinds
must be a top priority for hosting
governments
and for all international organizations
mr president
today i have three urgent requests
first
we urge the security council to work for
an immediate ceasefire
and a political solution
prolonged conflict is in nobody's
interest
and will only prolong the suffering of
the most vulnerable
the life-saving medicine we need right
now is
this
second
we urge all donors to support the
response to humanitarian needs
in ukraine and neighboring countries
which are immense and escalating every
day
thanks to donors
who front loaded whose contingency fund
for emergencies
we were able to respond immediately
deploying
these funds were supplemented
by additional funding
from the un
central emergency response fund itself
however
to sustain the response
we call on donors to fully fund the
united nations emergency appeal
as the under secretary general said it's
only 36 percent so far funded
we thank those donors who have already
pledged funding to meet the needs of
people in ukraine
and third
although ukraine is rightly the focus of
the world's attention
i urge you
not to lose sight of the many other
crises in which people are suffering
in afghanistan
more than half the population is in need
with widespread malnutrition and a surge
in measles among many other challenges
in ethiopia
the blockade of six million people in
tijrai for almost 500 days has created a
catastrophic food and health crisis
in the syrian arab republic
more than 12 million people are in need
of health assistance almost half of them
children
and in yemen
roughly two-thirds of the population
more than 20 million people are
estimated to be in need of health
assistance
mr president
in every case
the only solution
is peace
i repeat
in every case
the only solution is this and our world
needs peace more than ever
as if kovid is not enough
to have a devastating war like this
is dangerous for the world
i thank you
and back to you
allah
thank you mr president
and thank you to the briefers for your
briefing today
just three weeks ago
russia launched its unprovoked
unjustified
unconscionable full-scale invasion into
ukraine
and assault
on democracy
now over three million refugees have
fled the country
creating a devastating humanitarian
crisis felt around the world
these refugees are mostly women and
children
they stuffed their lives into backpacks
and left their homes and everything
they knew behind
today
many of them know that their apartment
buildings and streets
have been bombed to rubble
and the horrors continue
for those who remain in ukraine
we just heard from the whodg
that 43 hospitals have been attacked by
russia
43 hospitals and health facilities
ap reporters on the ground showed the
world a mass grave in mario pool
a narrow trench
filled with the bodies of children
yesterday russian forces dropped a
powerful bomb that hit a maripool
theater
where hundreds of civilians were hiding
the russian word for children
was written outside the theater both
front and back in large white letters
that could have been seen from the sky
yet russian forces
bombed it anyway
local officials have told families to
leave their dead relatives lying outside
on the streets
exposed to the world
because it is simply too dangerous with
the bombs and shellings to hold funerals
i just met with ukrainian civil society
leaders
they reported that people standing in a
breadline
trying to get food to feed their
families were shot dead by russian
soldiers
they reported terror the terror that
russia is inflicting across ukraine on
the ukrainian people
russia will be held accountable for its
atrocities
there's only one way
one way to end this madness
president putin
stop the killing
withdraw your forces
leave ukraine once and for all
yesterday i listened to presidents
president zielinski's speech to the
united states congress and i was so
moved by his words his bravery and his
calls for help
and for peace
immediately afterward president biden
announced another 800 million dollars in
security assistance to help ukraine
defend itself
that's more than one billion dollars in
the past week alone
we're not doing this by ourselves
our allies and partners are fully
committed to surging assistance to the
and
ukrainians
are grateful to all of our allies and
partners who have opened their borders
and their hearts and welcome ukrainian
refugees
we are also going to continue to provide
humanitarian relief to support people
within ukraine and those who have been
forced to flee
including the 186 million dollars in
additional assets assistance that
secretary blinken announced on tuesday
here at the united nations we believe
the best way to address the humanitarian
crisis is through a resolution in the un
general assembly
the resolution in the general assembly
will reflect the views of the
overwhelming majority of u.n member
states and ukraine itself
the international court of justice
issued a profound and important order
yesterday to the russian federation
and we call on russia to comply
immediately
russia has clearly violated
international law by violating the
sovereignty and territorial integrity of
ukraine
russia's brutal tactics have killed
civilians
medics and some of the journalists who
have been showing us all the truth of
this war
russia has attacked so much of what we
hold sacred
and everything
everything
the united nations stands for
russia's actions must be condemned
in no uncertain terms
as president biden said
ukraine will never be a victory for
putin
no matter what advances he makes
no matter whom he kills or what cities
he destroys
ukraine will never be a victory
for him
the united states stands with ukraine
and the ukrainian people
and we will do everything
everything in our power to end this
tragic
unnecessary war
thank you
representative of the united states for
her statement and give the floor to the
representatives of albania
thank you mr president
thank you rosemary for your clarity and
the very valuable information you
provide every time you come to brief the
council
thank you mr mazzu and director general
yagrasius for your sobering information
dear colleagues three weeks into this
unprovoked unjustified illegal and
deadly aggression by russia and the
terrible facts are hardly surprising
since anticipated nearly to the detail
massive casualties
among civilians
mass graves
widespread destruction of civilian
infrastructure ruined homes schools and
hospitals
lives blown away by bombardments
children dreams shared into smoke
there is no need to describe this
devastating situation
yet as we just heard
and by the top u.n representatives not
by the so-called west hysteria
is soul-wrenching and coincides with the
shocking media reports on the horrors of
the war
that and the misery unleashed upon
ukraine for no reason
i will maybe just recall the summarizing
words of the secretary general when he
said two days ago
ukraine is in fire and is being
decimated
guessed by who
over three million
three million refugees in only three
weeks
more than the entire population of my
country
some 2 million people displaced
internally
12 million people affected in the area's
hardest hit by the war
unicef has evidence that since the start
of the war forced by this brutal
aggression
every second a child has crossed the
border of ukraine
srsg patton warns that abuse
risks of sexual and gender-based
violence as well as
trafficking
continue to mount amid wide-scale
displacement
several appeals for humanitarian
corridors to evacuate civilians went
unheeded
many people remain trapped in areas and
conflict and with essential services
disrupted
are unable to meet their basic needs
including food water and medicine
for the estimated hundreds of thousands
who remain
there is simply nowhere to go
they can be killed even for queueing for
bread as it happened
this is the angry
and the true face of the russian
aggression
mr president
the director of who that we just heard
confirmed that there have been 33
attacks on ukrainian healthcare
facilities
infrastructure and workers since the
beginning of the invasion otherwise two
every day
there are unfortunately nearly a dozen
conflicts in the world today
out of 89 attacks on health system
around the world this year so far
33 have been only in ukraine
therefore attacking health care
facilities and workers is becoming a
tactic of war in ukraine
nothing is being spared
first there was this maternity ward in
maripora
then there was a mosque
yesterday russians bombed the drama
theater in mariopol
a shelter for nearly a thousand citizens
who are not able to flee the city
and as it was mentioned
the world children in large russian
script was painted on the ground outside
the theater
everything must be burnt
despite this grueling picture
the main news is not just what i said
the main news is that ukraine is holding
on
that ukraine is resisting
that ukraine is winning and russia is
deep in the mud
on the ground
morally
legally and internationally
and we know now that for russia to win
this war
of choice
it has to grozny the entire ukraine
it has to aleppo all its cities
it has to manipulate
everything there
and even after that we will be told here
again
that is not their fault
mr president
ukraine won yesterday the first legal
victory of the international court of
justice
icj the guardian of international law
ruled that there was no evidence to
support russian claims that ukraine was
committing genocide in the luhansk and
the nets
the court called for immediate
suspension of any kind of military
operations by russia and entities
organizations or persons under its
control
so the question is
will russia respect the court's order
or will it unplug and cancel itself
completely entirely from the
international law
mr president beyond the human toll the
infrastructure and residential
deliberate destructions and large-scale
humanitarian crisis
there is another major crisis the
economic impact of the aggression
undp has warned that every day of the
late peace will accelerate a free fall
into poverty in ukraine
unttp again
projected yesterday
that 90
of the ukrainian population could be
facing poverty and extreme economic
vulnerability should the war deepen
in the event of a continuing protracted
war in ukraine
almost one third of the population will
fall
below the poverty line and a further 62
percent
will be at re extreme risk of falling
into poverty within the next 12 months
it warned again the undp
that 18 years of social economic
achievement could be lost
and this would set the country and
entire region back decades
leaving deep social and economic scars
for generations to come
who in this room or outside it believes
than a single word from russia about
sdgs about agenda 2030 because these
terrible effects will not only be felt
in ukraine but in the entire world
mr president
russia has proposed a text for a
humanitarian resolution we think it is
wrong
it is worse it's a mockery of
proportions
a move worth of the guinness record of
hypocrisy
russia cannot shoot first and then come
disguised as a doctor
the only way to minimize humanitarian
consequences for the ukrainian
population
is simple
russia has to stop the war withdraw its
troops and go home
no one should get confused by a text
just because it is called humanitarian
when the only aim is to provide cover
for the war
so colleagues
don't fall for the new clothes of the
emperor
the russian aggression is naked out
there
thank you
and give the floor to the representative
of the uk
thank you mr president and i join others
in thanking our briefers today as well
as we've heard
it's three weeks since we met in this
chamber
to make one final effort to avert a
russian invasion of ukraine
it's three weeks
since we were interrupted by the news
that president putin had abandoned
diplomacy and chosen war
these have been three
devastatingly long weeks
for the people of ukraine
for the three million people who have
fled
and
for those who have stayed
as we heard from the un
russian forces are laying siege
to populated cities and towns and
indiscriminately
shelling residential areas with high
impact weaponry
including cluster munitions
43 healthcare facilities
including a maternity hospital
have been attacked
killing the most vulnerable
and depriving civilians of access to
medical assistance
and presidents putin's war
is causing suffering
well beyond ukraine's borders
thousands of students many from nations
around this table have been caught up in
the violence
the war is spiking food and energy
prices
bringing further pain
to countries in the developing world
already suffering from the impact of
covid and famine and conflict and
climate
millions of refugees have been taken in
by countries across europe
mr president
colleagues
three weeks since the start of russia's
invasion one point should be clear in
our minds
this is an unprovoked war of aggression
waged by russia
russia is responsible for the suffering
it has inflicted on ukraine and beyond
russia alone
can end this war
141 u.n member states have unequivocally
condemned russia's illegal invasion
the international court of justice
has issued a legally binding order
requiring russia to suspend military
action in ukraine
immediately
this week
perversely
russia tabled a resolution
that among other things
called for the protection of civilians
including women and children
this
is cynical game playing
in the face of human suffering
just yesterday
in mario poll
russian forces reportedly targeted
civilians taking cover from the
onslaught
despite the word children
written on the ground where they
sheltered
if russia
really wanted to protect women and
children
it would withdraw its troops from
ukraine
and end this illegal invasion today
thank you mr president
escorted
you representatives
and medical personnel
is
of armed
by the officers
situation in ukraine
is in its massive combination of russia
and many countries in france have
immediately taken measures
targeting russian authorities
economic circles close to the ocean
powers
cut off access to their resources
thank you president i also would like to
thank under secretary general de carlo
assistant high commissioner mazu and
director general dr teddrus for their
very sobering briefings
their messages are grim very grim
we commend all humanitarian
organizations working to alleviate the
man-made catastrophe
being visited on ukraine
president the cause of this catastrophe
is clear
three short weeks ago as we sat in this
very chamber as the secretary general
pleaded for peace
the russian federation invaded ukraine
since then
we have witnessed wanton devastation in
a sovereign independent nation with no
regard for human life
to date over three million people have
had to flee ukraine becoming refugees in
neighboring countries
we heard today 90 of those forced out of
their homes and into
uncertainty are women and children
families torn apart
at least 2 million people are internally
displaced
increasingly vulnerable and in need of
immediate support
ordinary people traumatized by a cruel
and reckless war
women and girls face heightened risk of
being subjected to sexual and
gender-based violence
including rape and trafficking
their right to protection is being
ignored
the destruction of the basic services
all of us here at this table take for
granted food water sanitary systems
health and education
is having a devastating effect in
ukraine
civilian casualties we know are in the
thousands
irish journalists pierre sachewski
was tragically killed alongside
ukrainian journalist sasha kushnova
they were both working to shine a light
on ukraine crane's plight
thoughts are with their families
and every grieving and suffering
ukrainian family
courageous journalists are showing the
horrific impact of russian aggression
i salute the free media putting their
lives on the line to show us the truth
the humanitarian impact of this war is
being felt around the world
it will affect the food security of
countries heavily reliant on ukrainian
agricultural products including in
africa asia and the middle east
it will cause severe harm far beyond the
borders of ukraine
president i find it a damning indictment
that this council has to plead with the
russian federation
not to deprive civilian populations of
food and water
not to deny them the basic
infrastructure they need for daily
existence
for survival
it's a damning indictment
that we in this council have not been
able to speak with the united voice to
save innocent lives in this
war president the images from the
besieged mario pool are shocking
we see once again
that urban warfare takes the heaviest
toll on civilians
we deplored the targeting of health care
facilities doctors taken hostage
life-saving care interfered with by
military forces
last week's attack by russian forces on
a maternity hospital in mariopol
plumbed new depths resulting in the
death of a mother and her newborn baby
a baby that never had a chance
we have to ask how many more
the residents of mario paul have are now
melting snow or siphoning water from
heating systems to quench their thirst
they're cutting down trees for firewood
for cooking
and to stay warm in freezing night
temperatures
the city's supermarkets emptied because
the basic necessities of life cannot be
safely brought into the city
it is chilling to think that the
suffering forced unmarriable
may be visited on other ukrainian cities
there can be no justification for this
brutal aggression
it should never have been perpetrated it
must be stopped
ireland calls on the russian federation
to comply with its obligations to
protect civilian health care facilities
and medical and humanitarian personnel
it must facilitate the safe passage and
unhindered delivery of humanitarian
assistance including medical and food
supplies
whatever is agreed or not agreed on
humanitarian corridors or other measures
civilians and civilian infrastructure
must be protected under international
humanitarian law
this applies both to those who choose to
leave
and those who choose to remain
surely the most basic respect for human
life must mean something to the
aggressor even now
let's be clear the provision of
humanitarian assistance is not dependent
on a ceasefire
it is dependent on those bombing cities
doing the right thing in accordance with
their obligations
president attacks directed against civil
civilians and civilian objects
indiscriminate attacks and
disproportionate attacks
are all prohibited under international
humanitarian law
ireland remains gravely concerned by the
humanitarian harm arising from use of
explosive weapons in populated areas in
ukraine
there have been reports of the use of
cluster munitions and thermal barrick
weapons by russian military forces
these weapons cause mass casualties
they pose great risk for civilians when
deployed in urban areas including long
after fighting has ceased
their use is unconscionable
equally
any use of white phosphorus against
civilians or civilian infrastructure
is apparent and contrary to
international law
president not only is russia's war in
ukraine morally wrong
it is illegal
yesterday in granting ukraine's request
for provisional measures against the
russian federation the international
court of justice was clear
it was emphatic
russia must immediately suspend the
military operations in ukraine
in light of the court's decision which
is binding on the russian federation
which it cannot ignore
ireland once again calls on the russian
federation to comply with its
obligations under international law and
immediately end its aggression
unconditionally withdraw its forces from
the entire territory of ukraine
and refrain from further threat or use
of force of any kind
against ukraine or any other member
state
president colleagues for three long
weeks
diplomacy has proved unavailing
for three long weeks the world has
watched this war with horror
yes
we believe there is still a chance for
peace
we urge the russian federation to do the
right thing
and commit to the diplomatic path in
good faith
it is never too late to do the right
thing
thank you president
i join others in thanking briefers for
their sobering presentations
three weeks ago russia launched its
military aggression and invaded ukraine
and since the start of the war a
ukrainian child has become a refugee
almost every second
our three million civilians have crossed
the borders into neighboring countries
seeking protection
and over 2 million people are displaced
inside ukraine
they are fleeing from the horrors of
russia's unjust and illegal war against
ukraine
from the destructive power of one of the
world's biggest war machines
from russia's shelling of homes schools
and hospitals
from russia's indiscriminate use of
explosive weapons
and their deplorable use of cluster
bombs
weapons that destroy cities
killing civilians even while they are
fleeing or hiding
the human suffering is unacceptable
we encourage countries to keep their
borders open to all those seeking safety
outside ukraine
without
discrimination and we commend the
generosity of the neighboring countries
and their solidarity with those fleeing
the war
many of those fleeing are in a
vulnerable situation as we heard from dr
teddrus at risk of sexual and
gender-based violence trafficking and
other forms of exploitation
traumatized children and adults in need
of mental and psychosocial support
we encourage the humanitarian
organization to give priority to these
issues in their response
president
civilian must be protected at all times
and humanitarian and medical worker must
also be protected and allowed safe rapid
and unhindered access to people in need
the protection of civilians and
humanitarian access are not a matter of
choice
they are legal obligation under
international humanitarian law
obligation which must be respected
and those responsible for violation must
be held accountable
president russia's war is causing
despair and suffering with global
implication
russia is responsible for the increased
food prices and higher risk of food
insecurity that many countries now face
russia's war against ukraine will
further exacerbate humanitarian crisis
death and disaster for people across
continents
russia and russia alone bears the sole
responsibility for the war and
humanitarian crisis
russia must stop its military aggression
against ukraine
russia must comply with the order by the
international court of justice to
immediately suspend its military
operation in ukraine
if russia cares about the humanitarian
suffering this war is causing
then russia should stop its senseless
and illegal war
the russian draft resolution has no
credibility it will not stop the war and
the suffering
we echo the call of the secretary
general
that political dialogue negotiation and
mediation are the only way forward
we need to see genuine talks that
translate into concrete results on the
ground
and they must be inclusive
we need to see women included
meaningfully in all talks negotiation
and mediation efforts
and for the sake of humanity
this war must stop
thank you
for watching
thank you mr president
let me thank usj de carlo
unhcr assistant high commissioner
mazzo
and who director general dr
gabrezas for their respective briefing
on the security and humanitarian
situation in ukraine
india continues to remain deeply
concerned at the ongoing situation
which has progressively deteriorated
since the beginning of the hostilities
the conflict has resulted
in death of civilians displacement of
thousands of people internally
and outflow of more than 3 million
refugees to neighboring countries
the humanitarian situation has worsened
particularly in the conflict zones
there is an urgent need therefore to
address the humanitarian needs of the
affected population
in this regard we support the
initiatives of the u.n and its agencies
who have mobilized whatever is possible
in the shortest possible time frame
we hope the international community will
continue to respond positively to the
humanitarian needs of the people of
ukraine including through extending
generous support to secretary general's
flash appeal and the regional refugee
response plan on ukraine
keeping in view the dire humanitarian
situation unfolding in ukraine india has
already sent over 90 tons of
humanitarian supplies to ukraine and its
neighbors as a part of the nine separate
tranche of humanitarian assistance
delivered thus far
these supplies have included medicines
and other essential relief material
we are in the process of identifying
other such requirements and sending
further supplies in the coming days
india has ensured the safe return of
about 22
500 indians from ukraine
we have also assisted nationals from 18
other countries in that process
we are deeply appreciative of the
facilitation rendered by the authorities
of ukraine and its neighboring countries
in ensuring their safe return
allow me to underscore that it is
important that the humanitarian action
is always guided by the principles of
humanitarian assistance which is
humanity neutrality impartiality and
independence
these measures should not be politicized
we reiterate our call for immediate
secession of hostilities across ukraine
our prime minister has reiterated this
on several occasions and called for
immediate ceasefire and emphasized that
there is no option but the path of
dialogue and diplomacy
we stand ready to continue to engage on
these objectives in the security council
as well as with the parties in the
coming days
we continue to underline the need to
respect the u.n charter international
law and the sovereignty and the
territorial integrity of states i thank
you mr president
and i now give the floor to the
the representative of ghana
mr president
i thank you for convening this meeting
and also thank the distinguished
briefers for the updated information on
the prevailing humanitarian situation in
ukraine i also welcome the participation
in this meeting of the representatives
of poland and ukraine
mr president
ghana reha trades once more the call on
the russian federation for an
unconditional and immediate cease-fire
and for the withdrawal of all its
invading troops from the internationally
recognized borders of ukraine
the cessation of hostilities is critical
to save lives and prevent further
devastation to the ukrainian people
it remains fundamental to addressing the
worsening humanitarian situation
we remain deeply concerned about the
military escalations and the
disproportionate use of unconventional
munitions in bombarding the cities and
civilian populated areas of ukraine and
we are disheartened by the trauma that
the situation has caused especially to
the aged women and children
the parties to the conflict must
urgently commit to a humanitarian course
to enable this evacuation and safe
passage of civilians and facilitate the
delivery of food medicine and other
essential services to those in critical
need and those who have been caught up
in the cities under siege
we also deplore the attacks on medical
facilities and call for the protection
of humanitarian workers and medical
personnel
we urge the parties to comply with their
commitments under international law and
international humanitarian law in
particular the provisions of the fourth
geneva convention of 1949
relating to the protection of civilian
persons in the time of war
we continue to urge the parties to
accept the path of diplomacy and
dialogue in resolving their security
concerns
we believe that the good officers of the
secretary general should be leveraged to
facilitate a peaceful resolution of the
conflict
mr president
in concluding i wish to emphasize that
the interest and safety of the ukrainian
people should be prioritized and must be
at the forefront of the actions of this
council and all other international
actions i thank you for your kind
attention
the population
the disruptions
and humanitarian personnel as well
around
avoid a stagnation in this situation
and i now give the floor to kenya
mr president uh i thank the briefers for
their presentations this afternoon
kenya is gravely concerned that three
weeks on
the armed conflict in ukraine has
continued unabated
the continuing reports of loss of lives
and displacement and separation of loved
ones including through
millions of refugees in just three weeks
is deeply disturbing
kenya extends
its condolences to the families who have
lost loved ones to the conflicts and
stance in solidarity with all the
affected
we commend ukraine's neighbors
for opening their borders to refugees of
multiple nationalities
and we urge them to continue ensuring
that protections
sought are offered with no
discrimination on any basis and
particularly in regard to race or
religion
kenya condemns the targeting on and
destruction of civilian objects
and infrastructure
particularly residential homes hospitals
and shelters
the parties are obliged to comply with
international humanitarian law
we remind that civilians including
foreign nationals in ukraine are not
party to the conflict and must not be a
target
in this regard
all
actors including the parties must
consider to prioritize the safety and
interest of civilians in accordance with
international humanitarian law
the imperative to ensure that
humanitarian passages are open and
functioning in all times cannot be
overstated
we believe that
these an urgent need for humanitarian
resolution that reflects the unity
and the resolve of this council to
assist the people of ukraine
ultimately
the only way out of this crisis is an
immediate
and unconditional cessation of the
military campaign
we urge the parties to do this to allow
humanitarian assistance to flow and
create room for diplomacy and
constructive dialogue including through
the good offices of the un secretary
general towards a sustainable political
solution
we underscore the need for an urgent
resolution of this armed conflict
its impact is already being felt through
increased food prices fertilizer oil and
other essentials by multiple countries
if it is not quickly prevented this
trend including
the added effects of unilateral
sanctions will aggravate
state fragilities
and fuel ongoing conflicts across the
world especially in the global south
in closing mr president
kenya
restates its recognition of the
sovereignty
territorial integrity and the political
independence of ukraine i thank you
for and i now give the floor to the
representative of brazil thank you
mr president
at the outset
i would like to thank for their
briefings miss jos marie de carlo
the wto director general tetrus gabrezus
and mr rauf mazu from wayne
unhcr
as the conflict in ukraine lingers on
the dire humanitarian situation in the
region is further deteriorating
brazil is deeply concerned with the
growing number of civilian casualties
including children
as well as the increasing flows of
refugees and internally displaced people
according to some estimates
the number of
people impacted by the conflict is
around 18 million
of which more than 6 million are
internally displaced and nearly 3
million people have flattered ukraine
the destruction of infrastructure has
caused food shortages energy outages and
intermittent communications
under these circumstances
supply chains have been disrupted
the access to medical facilities is
impaired
medical supplies are running low
their distribution is uncertain and some
stockpiles are out of reach due to
military operation operations
hospitals and medical personnel are
struggling to provide care to the sick
and wounded
in response to the most pressing needs
for humanitarian assistance
the brazilian government has sent last
week a donation encompassing water
purifiers around nine tons of foods
and half a ton of medical items
totaling approximately twenty thousand
twenty thousand items donated by the
brazilian ministry of health
with the assistance of the embassy of
reserving warsaw
the supplies were landed at that capital
and delivered to ukraine in coordination
with the country's authorities
the international community must come to
the assistance of the people most in
need
not only those directly afflicted by the
hostilities in ukraine territory
but also refugees in the neighboring
countries
we commend
the world health organization for its
work to ensure the delivery of health
supplies to ukraine and its neighboring
countries
the availability of medical personnel
medicines and health equipment is
crucial to meet the urgent needs of
those sick and wouldn't
at this moment ukraine's health system
is under critical pressure to cope with
the demands for assistance from the many
victims of this conflict
it is distressing
to know that as of 12 march
the world health organization
had verified 31 attacks
on health care facilities in ukraine
resulting in dozens of debts and
injuries including
health workers
the attacks against health care
are
particularly worrisome since they
deprive people of life-saving services
attacks on health care are violations of
international humanitarian law
we reiterate our position that the
immediate cessation of hostilities in
ukraine is the main condition to
guarantee the passage of civilians from
conflagrated zones to safe areas
moreover
only with a comprehensive and effective
ceasefire it would be allowed the rapid
safe and unhindered access to
humanitarian assistance to those in need
i thank you mr president
um
which is unfolding in a number of
regions in ukraine
security council are also rightfully
pointing to it
the difference here is that
assessments of some
particular western
ukraine is reaching new and new heights
and it started at the very beginning at
the uh
military operations
of uh such information from our
colleagues
um
[Music]
turkey
who
medical facilities in ukraine it's
something that we have many questions
about and we'll revert to that
journey however
this is the consequences of just
distributing weapons to whoever wants to
have them
but i do know who will hold the record
fakes
during one single meeting of security
council that will be a guinness book
record
the fabric manufacturing fakes
and the western
westerners are the situation
and around this city well let me explain
to you why this place is special
in the course of events in 2014
those who lived in the east of the
country uh it threw um planes and tanks
against them
speaking
and the mainstay of the voluntary nazi
battalions first and foremost the azov
battalion and the right sector one
airport
jail which is also a torture center with
all of the attributes
it has ditches with bodies of people
solitary confinement chainsaws this is
not even the uh middle ages this is near
nazism even the player that
is the ukrainian radicals are clinging
to this city so much first of all it
covers up maybe a proof of their crimes
second of all they understand that they
will have to be held accountable when
you go play at the moment and that's why
they stand already
to drag into
the grave almost entire uh population of
marijuana
exactly the way it was run by the nazis
in berlin in 1945 when it was besieged
they also hold people as human beings
they do not allow them to evacuate and
they place right next to residential
buildings heavy weaponry in violation of
international humanitarian law
yet
you to the icrc statement which sheds
lights light on these facts
in such a situation it's not a surprise
that mariupol has been
almost a leader
on the number and ingeniousness
[Music]
allegedly
[Music]
ignoring the opinion of ballistic
experts who say nothing hit the building
but rather there was an explosion there
after all the second fake something that
we heard about today also
russia allegedly hit the
by private
you are not surprised by the fact that
in front of the building you can see the
word children
the uh russian armed forces were
informed about the situation
and the building of the theater was
never considered as a target for a
strike
in such places such places of
provocation you can very frequently find
western reporters who briskly report on
that this is something that's become a
tragic hallmark of provocations in
ukraine who are covering up the excesses
conducted by national nationalist
battalions and ukrainian armed forces
once again
anything about the tragedy in donetsk
which resulted in 20 deaths
and the third fake now
allegedly
russia therefore only humanitarian
corridors into ukraine should be opened
this is a bare facelift
since the beginning of a special
hotline of the ministry of defense of
russia received more than 2.5 million
requests
requests for being evacuated into russia
unfortunately we have to state that
we have not been able to evacuate
everyone yet but this is because the
ukrainian authorities are prohibiting
but during the previous 24 hours alone
we managed to ensure the evacuation of
more than 31 000 civilians including 89
nationals
amongst whom 71 osce staff
the rest of them opted
and categorically refused to move over
to their territories and a key of
control
operation was conducted by the dnr
forces and russian armed forces without
any participation
i'd like you to draw your attention to
the fact
that
um
is 10 kilometers long
russian liberators and
the city this is not something that was
seen and this is not a surprise because
the peaceful civilians were needed for
by the nazis as a human shield
and those who escaped from
are telling us about mass atrocities and
crimes conducted by the territorial
defense about the abuses against the
elderly women and children and all of
these people and being individually
provided with medical and psychological
assistance
ukrainian side
objective control including with the use
of drones
[Music]
were not allowed
we're not allowing people to go
threaten them and those who managed to
break through were being
shot at
yesterday in the hardcore direction once
again there was a column of buses full
of refugees they're moving along the
humanitarian corridor towards russia's
[Music]
four hundred and forty people out of
them two thousand two hundred and forty
two children it was nice concerning
overall since the beginning of a special
military operation already two hundred
and seventy one
thousand people out of them fifty eight
children have been um
evacuated basically
they have crossed the border of russia
this includes a 31 000 individual cars
and we stand ready to take even more
russian federation we have more than 9.5
000 points of temporary housing
humanitarian assistance which remains in
many places the only possible means of
survival
medicine
which are received from international
organizations in particular
the mayors of ukrainian cities resell to
local entrepreneurs
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
and this also is related to the possible
provocations of by the ukrainian armed
forces
tons of food medicines and basic
necessities
overall starting with the second of
march our
emergency services and the ministry of
the
defense supply to
various regions of ukraine including
donbass supplied about 3 000 tons of
humanitarian cargo including
construction materials
another issue here
of cases the local administrations are
threatening punishment to those who
received
basically every day we
see um
information from western capitals that
they are providing kiev with yet another
um cargo of all kinds of weaponry
yesterday washington announced that this
week ukraine will receive from then
defense assistance to the amount of one
billion dollars
you are fueling uh this conflict pouring
oil
simply distributing light's weapons to
anyone who wanted them without any
control i wonder
whether the western
taxpayers about the risks of this
weaponry ending uh
um
with the terrorist groups in europe
political air defense weapons for
example do you understand how dangerous
it is to fuel the situation how
dangerous it is for your own security
it was not noticed even though it
crossed over several countries from the
western point in in ukraine to zagreb
that's 700 more than 700 kilometers
mr president
we
[Music]
uproar
it stopped being humanitarian
immediately and became full of
political formulas which have nothing to
do with humanitarian issues
we were clearly told the western
countries didn't need this project
without them
in order
they are ready to push it forward not in
the security council but in the general
assembly ignoring the fact that such
this kind of document will help
humanitarians nothing
and this is not the kind of assessment
that you can find another
humanitarian resolutions either and we
open this document for the
co-sponsorship by all you and members
of the humanitarian resolution submitted
by russia
is not something that satisfies western
countries
[Music]
and this shows the true goal sponsor of
many colleagues
that their arms are being twisted
including blackmail and blackmail and
threats
uh
it is for those countries to withstand
this kind of onslaught
therefore
this stage not to ask for a vote
we are not withdrawing the draft
resolution
instead
in the course of the special military
operation
and right now
we are going to forward the letter on
that to the emirati presidency i thank
you
for being here
about the worsening humanitarian
situation in ukraine and deplores the
reported increase in civilian casualties
and refugees
the pressing task now is to call for
maximum restraint from all parties and
to ensure safety and security of all
civilians including women and children
and meeting their basic humanitarian
needs so as to prevent the occurrence of
a larger scale humanitarian crisis
china supports the work by the relevant
parties in maintaining communication
ensuring safe and an impeded
humanitarian corridor and further
facilitating personnel evacuation and
humanitarian assistance
the number of refugees and displaced
persons caused by the conflict is still
on the rise
huge impact on ukraine and the
surrounding countries
china
and who among others effectively
conducting operations and mobilizing the
international community to assist
all those in need
in the recent past
some people of african or middle east
descent
encountered difficulties during
evacuation
this should be taken seriously and
addressed properly
all refugees regardless of color race or
religion
shall be accorded the necessary
protection and the international refugee
law
china pays high attention to the
humanitarian situation in ukraine and
has put forward a six-point proposal the
red cross society of china has provided
ukraine with three batches of
humanitarian supplies
with the third one containing
milk powder and quilts for children
specifically helping the red cross
society of ukraine assist displaced
children affected by the conflict
we welcome
any initiative or proposal from any
party that contributes to alleviating
and resolving the humanitarian crisis in
ukraine
the security council has a primary
responsibility for maintaining
international peace and security and
should never play a positive role in
easing the humanitarian situation in
ukraine china hopes that the council can
stay united on the humanitarian issue
and demonstrate a constructive attitude
mr president
the international community shares the
common aspirations for ceasefire at an
early date to elevate the situation on
the ground and to prevent civilian
casualties this is also the aspiration
of china
to date
russia and ukraine have held four rounds
of negotiations
keeping the negotiations going means
there is a chance for ceasefire
and that there is a chance for a
peaceful future
china remains committed to promoting
peace through negotiations we support
the u.n and the parties concerned in
vigorously carrying out good offices we
also hope
that all parties will do more to
facilitate peace talks
not to
add fuel to fire
that wanting use of sanctions will not
solve any problem but will instead
create new problems
given the sluggish recovery in global
economy
ever-escalating sanctions
are undermining stability in
international industrial chain and
supply chain thus exacerbating food and
energy crisis damaging people's
livelihood in all countries developing
countries in particular
and triggering new humanitarian
consequences this is also an issue that
the security council shall pay attention
to when addressing the humanitarian
situation in ukraine thank you mr
president
of mexico
is
almost
[Music]
continues
all those countries that have received
refugees especially those
the needs of those who do not have
access to business
is
[Music]
organization has recorded 43 attacks on
medical institutions in ukraine and the
fact that
honestly
over
against
them against
inadmissible they are
foreign
time
united nations
now is the time as well to reiterate
that the only solution
in ukraine could receive thank you very
much
foreign
civilians
and other
oh
is
especially
the importance of adhering
civilians
the uae
a solution to the crisis can only be
thank you very much i was momentarily
pleased to hear that the russians
were pulling down the vote on their
fascicle humanitarian resolution which
was doomed to fail
we know if russia really truly cared
about humanitarian uh crises the one
that it created it could simply stop its
attacks on the people of ukraine but
instead they want to call for
another security council meeting to use
this council as a venue for its
disinformation and for promoting its
propaganda
let us not forget that russia is the
aggressor here they are the ones that
are creating a pretext for attacks on
their own people
and we can't be fooled by by their
efforts here
they have troops inside of ukraine they
are killing people inside of ukraine
that is the reason for us being here
today not to deal with their propaganda
thank you
mr president
distinguished members of the security
council
madam under secretary
general dicarlo
director general assistant high
commissioner
i also recognize the representative of
the aggressor state present here in the
permanent seat of the soviet union
let me begin with a quote
the operation is developing successfully
and in strict accordance with plans
that have been previously
approved
end of quote
said by putin yesterday
three weeks after the unprovoked and
unjustified russian invasion of ukraine
started
over these weeks the international
community was wrestled
with the question
why
why has the russian federation decided
to cosplay the nazi third reich
by attacking the peaceful neighboring
state
and plunging the region into war
what are the reasons and what is the
plan
and yesterday we got the answer
killing ukrainian children
108 innocent souls so far
let me quote again
success
in the strict accordance
with the plans
approved
previously
according to putin
children are deliberate target
given yesterday's bombardment of the
mario paul drama theater
a shelter for hundreds of local
residents mostly women and children
despite the big signs
children painted on the road on both
sides of the building being clearly
visible
russian pilots dropped an aerial bomb
the building was fully damaged but the
shelter fortunately withstood
it did not turn into one of more mass
grave
as putin's plan probably
envisaged
previously approved
of course putin's plan does not limit
murders to children only
all civilian ukrainians and foreign
citizens are under threat
the office of the high commissioner for
human rights recorded 726 confirmed
cases of killing of civilians
while believing that the real figures
are considerably higher
and they are indeed
just yesterday in the city of chernihev
53 civilian residents were killed by
russian bombs and shells
on the same day
in marefa
harki region
21 people were killed following russian
shelling that destroyed the local school
and residential buildings
the plan is also to raise ukrainian
cities to the ground kharkiv sumi walnut
akhtirka
pain for ukraine and the entire world
and an eternal shame for russia
almost
2400
confirmed victims among the civilian
population
90 percent of the city's infrastructure
has been destroyed
russian troops seized one of the
hospitals
gathered 400 civilians there and used
the building as a military position
hiding behind civilians as a human
shield
let me quote
the sufferings of mariupol must not
become the future of ukraine end of
quote
said by peter maurer the icrc president
who is currently in ukraine
the plan of putin is to violate the
agreements on ceasefire and safe passage
for the civilian population from the
temporarily occupied territories
yesterday russian troops shelled a
convoy of civilian vehicles headed from
mariupol to zaparilla
five people were killed
many injured including children
and the plan is previously approved
to terrorize local residents who remain
in the territories ceased by russian
troops
small villages where the russian
soldiers stay suffer the most
russians break into houses
throw people out into the streets
take their food
eyewitness reports of tortures
abductions of local officials and even
extrajudicial killings come from across
the occupied territories
enforcing ukrainians to flee their homes
as refugees has also been a part of this
barbarossa style plan
almost 3.2 million refugees have left
ukraine so far
against the backdrop of the increasingly
aggravated humanitarian situation russia
has there to table
a draft humanitarian resolution of the
security council
an appeal by a serial killer
to the end members to co-sponsor this
most egregious hypocrisy is outrageous
they may like to think twice
if they want before they rather before
they dive into the blood of children and
adults executed by the russian military
in ukraine
and let me quote saint patrick in this
regard
never trust a dog to watch your food
at the same time there is no doubt
that action on the humanitarian front in
the u.n is urgently required and i
encourage all responsible nations to
support the relevant efforts in the
general assembly
i also encourage all to join the group
of friends of accountability following
the aggression against ukraine
co-founded by albania colombia
denmark the marshall island
islands the netherlands and ukraine
this group will act as a forum among um
member states for the discussion and
promotion of accountability measures in
ukraine following the russian military
aggression
distinguished members of the security
council
yesterday the international court of
justice delivered its order on
provisional measures in the case
concerning allegations of genocide under
the convention on prevention and
punishment of the crime of genocide
ukraine versus russian federation
the court ordered that the russian
federation shall immediately suspend the
military operations that it can
commenced on the 24th february 2022
in the territory of ukraine
despite the order being binding on
russia under the iran charter today the
kremlin has openly and bludently
disregarded it
stating that they and i quote cannot
take this order into account end of
quote because there is no i quote
agreement between the sites
and the quote
and should it be surprising for us
i don't think so
as from the very first instance of
russia's presence in the u.n it was in
content of the u.n charter
that was the case when russia was
allowed to occupy the soviet seat in the
u.n and the security council that was
the case in georgia
in syria
as well as in ukraine crimea and on bus
in 2014
i encourage the security council members
to exercise their duties
envisaged by the article
94.2 of the u.n charter to make
recommendations or decide upon measures
to be taken in the case of russia's
failure to comply with the obligations
incumbent upon it under the judgment
rendered by the court
mr
president perpetration induce
traumatic stress although known as pits
is a form of post-traumatic stress
disorder
its symptoms are caused by being an
active participant in causing trauma
sufferers of pits
may be found in many roles
such as soldiers
or
executioners where they are expected to
cause trauma
including death
but diplomats
especially here in the united nations
especially here in the security council
compared to the more well-known and
understood ptsd
there are there appears to be greater
severity and different symptom patterns
for those affected by pits
the case of the military aggression of
russia against ukraine and the mass
atrocities perpetrated by the russian
army
ordered by putin and defended by the
russian diplomats
will be examined by scholars and
scientists
including in the areas of sociology
history
philosophy
psychiatry and theology
today however i would like to quote
from into the abyss
a documentary about executioners
of the death penalty
one guard began crying and shaking
uncontrollably
when i quote
the eyes of all the inmates
he had executed
began flashing before him
end of quote
ambassador
do the eyes of ukrainian children
women and elderly killed by the russians
flesh before you
if they do we may consider how to how to
sponsor
a decision
to help you deal with
perpetration-inducted traumatic stress
but now have some decency
and stop the egregious manipulation of
the security council
it is obscene
it would be too much dignifying
for the russian delegation if i end it
like here
like that
instead i would like
to quote a tweet
by dario francischini
the italian member of the government
who tweeted today
italy is really is ready to rebuild the
theater in mariupol
the cabinet of ministers
has approved my proposal
to offer ukraine the resources and means
to rebuild it as soon as possible
theaters
of all countries
belong to the whole humanity end of
quote
and i thank you
for
mr president distinguished members of
security council i would like to thank
uh
under secretary general
and the briefers for their important
interventions today
and i shall start by paying tribute to
the fearless ukrainian soldiers and
civilians alike
who defend their homeland freedom and
the u.n charter
they fight also for those who were
forced to flee i should also express
gratitude to the work done by the u.n
orchard unhsr
who and and its partners for maintaining
their
presence across ukraine and continuing
deliver to deliver the of the assistance
excellencies
the security council has gathered here
today to discuss the fastest growing
humanitarian and refugee crisis since
the second world war the consequence of
the russian aggression on ukraine
in light of this i would like to stress
the following points
firstly
this is 100 a war of choice
and the methods of waging it is also the
matter of choice
it is russia that decided to refer to
brutal force in discriminating weapons
as well as brutal siege tactics
now they go as far as targeting
journalists and kidnapping meyers of
ukrainian cities
in other words the aggressor decided to
change the nature of this conflict
it is a clear manifestation that the
russia deliberately
chose to create a humanitarian
catastrophe in ukraine and bluntly
disregards all the principles of
international communitarian law and this
should worry us all
actually disregarding the national law
has been a pattern that russia pursued
in syria and other places to underpin
this approach earlier today the kremlin
has rejected an order by the national
court of justice on the united nations
highest court to cease its attack on
ukraine
secondly
without resolving the dire humanitarian
situation there will be no peace
therefore we urge russia to change its
military modus operandi and allow full
and impeded crimentarian access and
relief to those in need
the safe passage of civilians from
different cities affected by the
conflict must be allowed
take the situation in mariopol where
still around 350 thousands residents
remain trapped in the city as food water
and medicines continue to dry up
these people require urgent humanitarian
assistance and are exposed to safety and
security risks therefore we call for
immediate ceasefire and humanitarian
access to most affected areas
thirdly
the humanitarian consequences of the
ongoing war are not limited to
ukrainians in their own territory
those who had fled remain affected too
already more than 3 million were forced
to leave ukraine as a result of russia's
military aggression
we have already reached the number of
over 1.9 million people who crossed our
border since february 24th
most of them found the shelter in poland
we have registered already 170
nationalities on our border
that means it considers us all and we
are all the victims of this aggression
excellencies
as a neighbor and close friend of
ukraine we see firsthand the dramatic
humanitarian consequences of this war
every day on the polish ukrainian border
we are witnessing growing number of
people who cross the border severely
traumatized
we believe that the involvement of u.n
bodies and agencies experience in
dealing with this kind of needs together
with the continued efforts of the polish
authorities will bring rapid and
appropriate solution
the spirit of solidarity poland will
continue to admit and provide shelter
food healthcare and safety to every
person in need regardless of their
nationality race or religious creed
aside from the
institutional curve thousands of polish
people are organizing in a bottom-up way
showing the solidarity of ukraine
opening their homes to refugees and
volunteering and reception centers
excellencies as i'm delivering this
speech paulin's president's spouse
agatha conhauser duda is building up
international coalition of first ladies
and high-end highnesses and all the
peoples of goodwill to effectively
protect those in vulnerable situations
namely women children elderly persons
and persons with disabilities many of
them with post-traumatic
disorder
the polish government has urgently
implemented new immigration measures for
ukrainian citizens fleeing their country
the new law that took effect on monday
legalizes the state of citizens of
ukraine in order to enable them to take
up employment and provide them with
healthcare education and accommodation
in poland it also offers temporary
financial help to polish citizens who
welcome refugees in their homes
ukrainian citizens may apply for
one-time subsidy to answer their basic
needs
the government will allocate funds for
schooling of ukrainian students
every ukrainian citizens fleeing the war
has been guaranteed access to the public
healthcare system in the same way as
police citizens have
we will continue to provide assistance
to ukrainian citizens fleeing the
horrors of war
brought on them by russia and i can tell
you already we got the 45 thousands of
pupils subscribed to public schools from
ukraine
but we and the other countries of the
region which i see the
ambassadors here in in the room we all
need urgently an assistance of
international assistance in these good
need
deeds
excellencies
today ukraine pays a high price for
defending its independence tertiary
integrity and democracy and you and
charter
the termination and courage of ukrainian
people inspires the world
we cannot fail them
it is crucial to show our solidarity of
ukraine and its people by acting now
and i think
representative of poland
no more names on my list of speeches
the missing is adjourned
militarize ukraine to densify it and to
make ukraine a neutral state which which
is not threatening russia
negotiating negotiating are going on
what evidence are you going to bring
tomorrow on chemical and violence i have
additional information on that and i
think it deserves it new information
that it deserves uh being discussed in
the security council and that's not
that's not a joke that's not a russian
propaganda because more and more people
in the west including us and and uk are
asking questions on that
military bio programs that that u.s was
conducting in ukraine and not just in
ukraine that that applies to many uh
u.s sponsored laboratories around the
world
are you planning to use biological
weapons
okay
agrees
okay
okay
is
all right
foreign
yeah nobody